I'm curious if Anthony Lin thought that
Joe Flacco was coming in that game the
Chargers head coach joins us the
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
coach congratulations let me start with
that question were you expecting
Joe Flacco you know what we would
propose to Joe and we did talk about
them on sidelines at one point that they
might put Joe in so if he came in the
game we'd have been ready the defense
that you came up with how long was that
in the works to have to you know being
able to go against Lamar Jackson a
couple of weeks prior how much of
advantage was that to that defense you
know it definitely gave us more looks
and and we had a chance to come up with
more tendencies that they were showing I
think winning you know when Lamar first
came on the scene it just wasn't a lot
of tape on him but the more games he
played you can started looking at the
table you to see some some tendencies
that they had and and it worked in our
favor because it was federal money
decent staff did a heck of a job of
dissecting that team and coming out with
things I could help our players what
happened in the fourth quarter there in
the final five minutes six minutes well
you know a lot but they went to that no
huddle and they actually blew the ball
pretty good in no heart'll and Lamar ran
around and he made some plays with his
long he made some plays with his legs
but no at the same time we could have
done a better job of staying on top and
not giving up big plays like we did have
you checked the weather forecast in New
England not really okay all right I just
curious like like every time we've gone
East we've gotten outstanding weather I
mean you go to Pittsburgh in December
and you're a Kansas City December
weather was just fine you go to Denver
and December the weather was just fine
so we've been blessed that way why are
you guys good on the road great on the
road you'd always tell football team and
you know we started you know one of the
things we want to be was tough
and then and the guys they have uh you
know they've responded they've been
through some adversity and then complain
you know make excuses they they stuck
together and they're really resilient
and and gritty and I just think those
type of teams and over there they're
gonna play well on the roads and I
wasn't one of those teams in Denver in
97 we play well in the road a year and
and it's same thing throughout the
playoffs but uh this team is built that
way man they care about one another and
and I think they can't like going into
these hostile environments where it's
kind of like you go in back-to-back no
having each other's back
they kind of like that can you name all
the Phillip Rivers kids have a big
family and other resources what a big
family I think that and it's never a
boring moment I can tell you that can
you beat him at a 40-yard dash you know
former running back at all but uh
yesterday you know we had a kid break
out on the interception that they called
back and I didn't serve some but the a
fumble recovery that they called back
and I mean setup I thought is really
catching his Humphrey Bobbie Humphrey
son and I started can run now and
running pretty good for a little while
how is that plane ride back for you guys
it was fun just fine you know as a long
plane ride back
you know the guys hydrated but uh it was
definitely fun Continental Tire Coach's
Corner brings us Anthony Lin the
Chargers head coach I saw where you
called Todd Haley brothers for life
and you can you give us this like the
Cliff Notes version of you know why you
feel like Todd Haley is a brother for
life for me and one of my worst moments
you know Todd and I was out having a
piece a couple pumps and I ended up
getting hit by a drunk driver and all
means part of the diet and I got hit by
a car going
an hour he was three times the legal
limit drunk but I survived and carp was
there with me the whole time I mean we
were friends before that but after that
night it was it was a it was a special
bond because I just remember him
confident me and telling me I was gonna
make it it's gonna be all right but I
really didn't think who was but uh that
was that was just a special moment just
the way he handled their situation and
you know and after that he went through
a lot you know cuz he watched me get hit
and fly 50 feet in air and land on the
other side of the road total Volkswagens
I landed on and he saw it on and it
really affected him for a long time and
you know he admitted me that he had to
get some help because he couldn't get
those visions out of his head and and so
we talked about this for years man and
and it just kind of made us closer yeah
I saw some reports said that you were
bloodied and unconscious you woke up and
Todd Haley's holding your head off the
ground yeah and then you didn't you
thought maybe you were paralyzed like
did did you wonder sometimes when you
get injured you don't realize how
injured you are it's somebody who's
there with you to say no no you're in
trouble here stay down did you need that
somebody like Todd telling you I
definitely needed because I had no idea
what had happened and I kept trying to
get up and I really couldn't get up and
I couldn't feel my legs and you know for
two days I couldn't feel my lower body
and so you know and then I was just
holding my head up off the pavement
making me comfortable as possible went
to the guy ran to the MLS but I don't
remember much about that night but I do
remember Todd being there and comforting
me and that meant a lot I love though
that you're saying like dude why are you
staring at me how the hell are you alive
we would be coaching meetings and I can
just feel someone just staring at me and
I look across the table my I can't
believe you're alive well then I mean
you can't be fearful going into New
England I mean it given what you've done
who cares where you go to Pittsburgh go
to Denver doesn't matter right no you
know what we'll play anybody
anywhere and you know it's gonna be a
heck of a challenge sunny in New England
you know those guys have been champions
for a long time there's one a lot of
hardware in his house you know let it be
known that you're gonna win it's okay
you gotta go through them and and we're
gonna go give it our best shot and you
know work on right now and getting that
guys prepared have outstanding coaches
stuff I know we will be prepared and
we'll see who executes the best you
bring your Super Bowl ring out at all
you know what don't because the teams
are won the Super Bowl rings with or in
the same damn division come on it's like
it's like dropping the mic just go in
there get your Super Bowl ring and just
drop it on the table and then walk out I
want to help these guys get their own
Super Bowl ring that's what I want to do
and then I definitely bring it out well
good luck and great season so far and
safe travels Thank You Anthony all right
that's Anthony Lynn he's the guy I was
reading the story on that we're came out
of a bar with Todd Haley who's the great
offensive coordinator and all of a
sudden it's like gets hit by a car the
one about 55 miles an hour and doctors
said you you know people don't live no
they thought he was he was gonna die a
hundred percent you know they were
saying so pretty amazing pretty amazing
story there so you know what's the big
deal I'm going to New England to face
Bill Belichick and Tom Brady Continental
Tire Coach's Corner Continental Tire
proud to be the exclusive tire the Dan
Patrick show no matter where you drive
what you drive how you drive Continental
design starters for what you do for more
information visit Continental Tire Calm
Continental Tire for what you do for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
you